we've gotten very lucky or maybe better
said we are very fortunate
that as soon as december 11th or 12th we
are expecting that people will start to
be vaccinated with one of two
coronavirus vaccines
that are believed to be 95 percent
efficacious
in preventing coronavirus now with flu
vaccines and other vaccines
we very often don't have near 95 percent
uh effective vaccines and we are on the
path to having multiple such vaccines
for coronavirus
the astrazeneca oxford vaccine also
announcing today
that their data shows it is a 90
effective vaccine so we are
on the way to very soon having two
vaccines going in the u.s
there's this third vaccine which has a
slightly different timeline that should
be available relatively soon
and yet herd immunity is still going to
be in jeopardy because of existing
anti-vaccine sentiment which could
absolutely
explode once the vaccine is available so
there's good news and there's bad news
here let's go over everything we know
pfizer and moderna each have coronavirus
vaccines
said to be 95 effective
huge based on phase 3 clinical trials
now the fda
and independent review groups are going
to be meeting for three days december 8
9 and 10
to decide about reviewing the data and
potentially granting an emergency use
authorization on one or both of these
vaccines
if they do that on december 10th you
could see people being vaccinated
on december 11th or december 12th we
desperately need vaccines
the virus is out of control we had a
24-hour period
this weekend with 200 000 new cases
we have had 1600 to 2000 people dying
per day
once again in the us of the virus and
yet
according to the latest gallup poll 42
percent of americans
say they would not get the vaccine
if there was an fda approved vaccine
today
that's really bad because if not enough
people
get this vaccine we are not going to get
to herd immunity and dr
anthony fauci talked about this over the
weekend when he appeared on cbs's face
the nation let's listen to him explain
it
to the hope the scientific advisor to
operation warp speed said this morning
we could have true
herd immunity take place somewhere in
the month
of may as the vaccine is distributed
does america go back to life
as normal in may uh
you know i don't think so uh unless we
do
and i believe you're referring to
monster salawi you said that and i
totally
agree with him but there are there are a
couple of things that go into the
effectiveness
of a vaccine program a highly
efficacious vaccine
and we're there we have two of them that
have a 95 percent
efficacy the other part of the equation
is how many people get vaccinated
so if you have a highly efficacious
vaccine
and only a relatively small 40-50
percent of the people get vaccinated
you're not going to get the herd
immunity you need what we do
need is we need to get as many people as
possible
vaccinated and that's why we want to be
very transparent for people
to understand the independent and
transparent process
that got us to the point of saying which
the fda will examine it very carefully
now
together with advisory committees that
are completely independent
and declare with an eua and ultimately a
license
that the vaccines are safe and effective
when the american public hears that
you should be assured that that is the
case and if you get
an overwhelming majority of the people
vaccinated with a highly efficacious
vaccine
we can reasonably quickly get to the
herd immunity that would be a blanket of
protection
for the country so of course he's right
and people saying that this vaccine was
rushed
it wasn't rushed this is a type of
vaccine based on an mrna
platform that just takes less time to
develop than traditional vaccines the
traditional coronavirus vaccines are
also being developed
we're expecting them in the second half
of 2021.
this was not rushed and anti-vaxxers are
going to be going absolutely crazy as
these vaccines roll out
and add to that people who just don't
think coronavirus is serious enough
to warrant getting a vaccine why well
because donald trump has been
downplaying it for a long time
now of course there will be
anti-vaxxers fear-mongering about
mandatory vaccines
there is not going to be a mandatory
coronavirus vaccine
what you will be seeing and we're
already starting to seeing it
starting to see it is that many sports
venues
concert venues hopefully even airlines
we've heard from qantas which said they
will be doing this
public schools maybe who will say after
a certain date you need proof of
vaccination to
attend come to a concert go to school
here
fly on our airline you don't have to get
a vaccine
but if you want to choose to come to a
sports game here
or fly on our airline you will have to
have a vaccine
ticketmaster already announcing they are
rolling out the infrastructure to be
able to do that
qantas so far the first airline i'm
aware of that announced that
that is something they're planning to do
i'm hopeful
that that will encourage sort of like as
a carrot rather than a stick
more vaccination and of course the
difference between
you having a vaccine that's 95 effective
versus everyone having it is huge if you
have the vaccine
and nobody else does and it's 95
effective it means that one out of 20
times
that you interact with someone with the
virus in a situation where you could get
the virus one out of 20
you will get the virus if you go back to
normal work
indoors without masks and interact with
a lot of people
you can quickly understand how a 1 in 20
shot at getting the virus even when
vaccinated
still leaves you quite vulnerable if
everybody
has a 5 chance of getting it from
everyone they interact to
by definition you are talking about herd
immunity and that is a very very
different thing
the only upside my last thought on this
the only upside to 40
of the country not wanting a vaccine is
that it means
a vaccine may be available for those who
do want them
sooner in other words me as someone who
is not
high priority on the vaccine list if
everybody wants a vaccine
i might not be able to get one until i
don't know may june even
if only 60 of the country want vaccines
it's plausible i could end up with a
vaccine in february or march
although overall society will be less
protected
that's the only upside i can see for the
people like me who are waiting for a
vaccine
uh let me know what you think we will
have more on vaccines uh later this week
and of course you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
for a limited time our sponsor purevpn
is offering you
a huge 86 percent discount on a
subscription
which comes out to only about a dollar
fifty per month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online and you can trust them
because they're the only vpn
in the industry with an always-on
third-party audit
to verify that your internet activity is
not being logged
by hiding your ip address purevpn keeps
you safe
from hackers and prevents you from being
spied on by your internet service
provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than
any other vpn in the industry everyone
should be using a vpn when connecting to
the internet and now is the perfect time
to start because purevpn is giving you
an
86 discount on a subscription which
comes out to only about a dollar fifty a
month
go to davidpakman.com purevpn
the link is underneath this video